well Mila Kunis is her second child with
Ashton Kutcher and the key to making it
all work
Phillipe amen I like to do what's called
the geriatric dinner which is about 5:30
6:00 p.m. dinner that's my favorite my
favorite put my daughter down at 7:00 in
bed by 9:00 oh it's so nice
that's Mila describing her perfect night
in getting candid for her cover story in
the August issue of Glamour magazine the
32 year old stunt in Bottega Veneta gets
playful in an oversized coach jacket
goes makeup free for a gorgeous back
cover and dishes on everything from
working out to Trump to pumps I think we
need to upgrade the breast pump because
I think everyone's sounding like a cow
can grow old but but it did save me and
I've pumped an airport I've pumped on
the side of the road I pumped everywhere
Mila opens up about her 18-year
relationship with now hubby Ashton
Kutcher saying quote there's nothing we
don't know about each other because
we've known each other for so long the
ugly the bad the good it truly is being
married to your best friend that's a
cliche it's cheesy but it's true I have
an amazing amazing support system in my
house my husband Paul Mila and Ashton
are going to be parents for the second
time so besides chasing after her
one-year-old daughter Wyatt how does
this mom stay in shape one word and
according to Mila it ain't pretty
I hate the word burpees like it
literally it's like PTSD for me because
my trainer loves burpees so much and you
see yup burpees when I go to 20 burpees
and I was like oh I hate them I'm crying
just thinking about them for her she's
right they're terrible any other know
anyone who likes them I don't like
crunches no but me a lot like you you're
looking awesome